Will the ldrn be present at this ceremony or not?
Is this 1 national tribute or not 1 pantheonization ceremony?
Well then it is addressed to all French people and
therefore the ballot boxes will be present.
Yes,
because if you start sorting,
we're going to have to uh Les les.
The supporters of Maurice Papon do not go,
that the supporters of François Mitterrand and Saint-Francisque do not go and that
some do not have other characters like that
do not go there So I think that today,
uh Pantheonization reveals,
I mean the sacred,
finally character of the character and that
it is addressed to all French people,
whatever their origins,
their conditions or their opinions.